the penguin features prominently in matt
reads the batman but did you know that
this famous comics character has seen
many different versions portrayed over
the years stay tuned to get a look at
how the penguin from the batman should
really look warning spoilers ahead
batman has been adapted for the big
screen by numerous filmmakers all of
whom have interpreted the character and
his stories in unique ways tim burton
embraced the popular element of gotham's
caped crusader while adding his
trademark gothic horror stylings to the
proceedings in 1989's batman and its
sequel batman returns joel schumacher
meanwhile leaned into the campia side of
the dark knight when he was tasked with
helming batman forever and batman and
robin elsewhere christopher nolan opted
for a more grounded and realistic
approach to crime fighting in the dark
knight trilogy the latest iteration of
the world's greatest detective on screen
comes from filmmaker matt reeves best
known for his work on cloverfield and
the most recent planet of the apes
trilogy the batman is a neo-noir
thriller with horror elements boasting a
story that focuses on a psychologically
damaged bruce wayne and his alter ego
batman as he proclaims himself to be
vengeance incarnate i'm vengeance
naturally the batman also takes some
creative liberties with the source
material and presents familiar
characters in fresh and interesting ways
the film's depiction of the penguin for
instance is a huge departure from any
other incarnations of the villain on the
screen but how is the character supposed
to look the penguin otherwise known as
oswald couple parts has been one of the
most popular villains in the batman
canon for decades known for his
umbrellas cigars extravagant tuxedo and
trademark waddle the crime kingpin has a
recognizable look that just screams
villainy over the years he has been
portrayed by the likes of burgess
meredith danny devito and robin lord
taylor all of whom established a firm
image of the character in the pop
culture imagination however colin
farrell's penguin and the batman isn't
the same menace whose grace previous
movies and tv shows for estars the cigar
top hat and tuxedo are all gone in
exchange for everyday gangster clothing
he does carry an umbrella at times but
it doesn't possess the ability to fire
bullets farrell who lobbied for a cigar
discussed the changes in a december 2021
interview with empire the actor
acknowledged the key alterations made to
the character but he also wants fans to
know that it's still early in
cobblepot's quest to become the familiar
foe he revealed us is not yet fully
inhabiting the mythology of the penguin
and doesn't take too kindly to the
penguin moniker it remains to be seen
how the penguin will evolve in the
batman franchise moving forward however
he will return to the fold in a
substantial way warner brothers has
major plans for the character so fans
can look forward to a more fleshed out
story at a later date while he probably
should have died in the batman the
penguin survived the chaos and will live
to fight another day in gotham's
criminal under belly warner brothers has
ambitious plans for the character who is
set to receive his own spin-off tv
series the story will reportedly
chronicle cobblepot's rise from
mid-level gotham gangster into the
grandiose crime kingpin he's typically
depicted as in the movies tv shows and
comics details about the series are
being kept close to the vest right now
but early reports have compared it to
scarface a mob saga that follows one
gangster's ascension in the criminal
underworld
of course it's highly likely that some
changes will be made to the penguin
character in this version of the dc
franchise most characters differ from
their older counterparts in some way
after all the batman gives us a menacing
serial killer version of the riddler who
wouldn't seem out of place in a movie
like seven then there's a joker who
despite being hidden behind a cell door
during his brief cameo in the movie
doesn't appear to resemble any previous
version of the character
in shorts it remains to be seen if the
penguin will rock top hats and fire
bullets from an umbrella in the spin-off
series and future movies at the same
time the unpredictability is exciting in
its own right and this will be
interesting to see it all unfold
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]